so let's just get our heads back in the
right space okay we won't get too
worried about this yet because
ironically that's actually for the next
pilot question but let's start off the
management of this doesn't matter it
could be any company right in fact it's
quite generic they want to generate
forecasts of big corporations
performance over the next five years so
again another DSS that's why we're in
spreadsheets the system must meet the
following requirements okay now
bla bla bla bla bla we're going to get
into the specifics in a second but the
important thing is that lesson we did
here there's a whole bunch of data
inputs that we're going to need to
include and so that's why Part A deals
with those nine inputs it says
identified plausible data sources
associated with each of the inputs okay
so all of these in one some way shape or
form appear in the all of those dot
points okay so let's think about it now
for three marks I wasn't looking for
like a super amount of detail is just
looking for you to give me something
reasonable okay so where is the
company's ABCs where are their past year
sale records gonna come from where would
you think I would think that probably
ABC right the ABC keeps their own
records for themselves it's not like
from somewhere else they'll just keep it
all in a database right probably called
the sales database that's all you needed
to say like ABC's sales database sorry I
think I need to calibrate this
I win sorry I think this is actually a
new computer that I'm using it looks
slightly shinier
all right so sales database now the same
way add the cost records there they're
going to come from different people
right so sort of like a where would you
which part of a company would have this
it's probably the accounts like we have
an Accounts Office right there the
people who manage all of our money
internally okay so you might just save
you cuts I accepted it if for both of
these
you just said company database I was
fine okay
I'm just looking for you to identify the
fact that where these gonna come from we
did the company okay all right now this
required a bit more thought kind of
future printed inflation rates now you
didn't actually need to I didn't I
wasn't assessing you as a commerce
student here okay but I was assessing
you for your ability to understand what
something wasn't you know translated to
a spreadsheet where's the image is
anyone know who defines you know
inflation and interest rates and like I
think it's the Reserve Bank of Australia
so you need to say something like RBA or
the government was okay right are both
three and four are both defined by
government bodies so Reserve Bank of
Australia who decides the taxes right
that's easier yes I would have said the
government but who we did the government
the ATO the Australian Taxation Office
okay okay now lastly careful now I was a
little more strict on this one
percentages increase or decrease in
sales and then percentage of total sales
for different cost categories and I
think the cost calories they mentioned
up here goods
admin marketing okay those are the
categories right so where is the
spreadsheet going to get these two
pieces of data for
now I did sort of accept two answers for
this last one percentage of total sales
some of you might thought oh this is
like sales records right I say guys so
you might have said sales database and I
would have accepted that okay but a
better answer is for both of these two
okay
they're actually what the user gets to
decide and muck around with they can
change that that's what makes this a
decision support system right so I think
up here it says here we go autos the
predictions as the user adjusts note
that right that's how you know this
isn't actually some historical data the
users just making it up what if we spent
20 percent on this or what if we spent
80 percent or whatever okay and in the
same way
let's see different forecasts inputs
right so this is thinking oh I don't
know we might make we might grow 10%
next to you as a company we're really
ambitious we're going to double in size
we're going to grow a hundred percent
okay what's going to happen to our
profits right so those are the different
forecast inputs which are going to go
into this yeah so both of these should
come from the user okay should come from
the user right now the fun begins okay
so we have to develop a pen and paper
spreadsheet design that does all this
stuff but so now let's dig into it a
little more it's doing forecasting okay
it's trying to predict right so let's
get into a little more detail and as we
go let's highlight the specific things
that are going to be inputs and outputs
that are going to go into a spreadsheet
okay let's generates accurate
predictions of post-tax profit for each
of the next five years
okay now that's a big mouthful but
that's kind of as you read through you
might realize that's the ultimate thing
that's our sort of endpoint and all the
rest of the calculations are here sort
of feed into that
okay so predictions of post-tax
profit okay and because you get to it
you know you can write in your papers
right you should get this and you can
set you should draw on it and say okay
this is an output okay right let's get
going alters the predictions
appropriately for different forecasts
inputs so we noted that already right
let's put that in a different color
because that's not an output is it
that's something that we get to decide
that's in okay in terms of total sales
increases or decreases right that's fine
alters the predictions as the user
adjusts okay look at this costs of goods
there's an input administration there's
an input and marketing now notice it
also says it's relative to total sales
made this total sales made so when
something's relative to another thing
right it's kind of like ah I spend ten
percent of my money on this and twenty
percent of that and 30 percent of this
so that's what makes it relative as
opposed to I spent 50 bucks on that well
what is that as a proportion of your
total sales don't know so all of these
three things here they're all going to
be percentages so just keeping track so
far I have four inputs one two three
four user display real data from at
least the previous year to verify the
inputs and predictions are realistic
okay so that's why I had said you know
you need past year's sales records okay
so I guess they probably got to get fed
in from a database like a query will
pull that information details cost
associated with producing of all of this
stuff for each prediction okay now when
it says each prediction right what that
tells you is I think whereas I say we
want five years in total right for this
spreadsheet so that means each
prediction each year is gonna only have
to be dealt with separately so one of
the important things I was looking for
in your design was that there had to be
five years worth of columns for you know
whoever 2014 2015 16 and so on okay
or something so that I could see you
understood that they were different
distinct predictions here for every
distinct year okay so that was really
important okay we're allowed to express
each of the above cost relative to total
sales so he's
Galatians that we happy detail actual
sales total required to meet predict
profits again for the calculation and
lastly forecasts will take account of
two external variables which were
mentioned down here inflation so there's
an input and Taxation rates there's a
tip worth okay so total I have one two
three four five six inputs right so now
I'm going to use those and they're going
to be the basis of my design I'm gonna
put down okay so here's what I was
looking for in your spreadsheet designer
firstly inputs okay and I just
identified six of them right so I'm
gonna run them out let's see let's do it
help me remember okay we had tax rates
we had and we also had all of those
percentages of those costs right so
three four five they're all going to be
percentages right off what was it what
we do we had goods admir'd marketing
so we as a company want to determine
okay how much should we spend on each of
these maybe our marketing by just really
small the moment and that's gonna be you
know not very good for us so we should
increase it versus average we spend on
you get the idea
all right now does anyone remember what
was the last one there's a sixth input
actually the first one we noticed here
we go different forecasts inputs so
that's us just making a guess of him
playing around with the numbers to think
yeah you know we've had a really good
fiscal year I think we're going to grow
by this much next year or maybe not so
much just maybe modestly okay so that's
what would you call that a Oh a growth
prediction if you like or you know a
sales increase how much more you think
you're going to sell over the coming
years and because you know this is going
to go from year to year to year it
should be a percentage as well so quite
a few of these things of percentages
yeah they're not in terms of raw numbers
I think I've grown by 1 billion dollars
you know that's it that's a hard thing
to quantify and every year it will
change ok yeah yeah yeah that's true ok
so I suppose you could call it
percentage sales change that that would
have been fine I guess I'm being an
optimistic hope you there every year we
get it grow okay no GFC that's gonna
screw us over but yeah that's true that
it could we could predict we could
forecast draw okay